i can confirm firstly that we expect to
lift the current state home rule
on the 2nd of april initially
although we hope this will be for no
more than 3 weeks
stay at home will be replaced by
guidance to stay local
in other words not to travel outside
your own local authority area
unless for an essential purpose people
will continue to be able to meet up
outdoors including in private gardens
and groups of no more than four from two
households
our other changes in early april will
take effect from
monday the 5th on that day we expect
contact sports for 12 to 17 year olds to
resume
we also expect that from 5th april more
students
particularly in further education will
be allowed to return to on-campus
learning
colleges will prioritize those students
whose return
is essential including those who are
most at risk of not completing their
courses
and that includes those who are taking
qualifications in construction
engineering
hairdressing beauty and related courses
we also expect to begin the phased
reopening of
non-essential retail on the fifth of
april click and collect
retail services will be permitted to
reopen from that date
along with homeware stores and car
showrooms and forecourts
and garden centres will also be able to
reopen on the 5th of april which i know
is important as we head towards the
summer period
and last but for some of us definitely
not least we expect hairdressers and
barber salons to reopen for appointments
on the 5th of april as well